>> WANT AS LEFTS UNRAVEL BECAUSA
TO TRAVEL.
AND WEE FOED TO FLY WITH
LIBERAL ABBERS INSTEADF CE
DIAPERS.
WE CAN SHOW O FAS AND IT'S
THE MASTS ARE CONG UP FASTE
THAN JESSE WAERS TO PAY AT
BEDTIME.
IWILL NEVER GET UD TO SEEING TH.
YESTERDAY, U.S.DISTRICT JUDGE
STRUCK DOWN THE MASKMANDAT
AT REQUIRED FACE CORINGS
PLANES,TRAI, AND BUSES.
THE BITE IN THE MINISTRATI
PLS ON APPEALING T DECISION
YOU STILL HAVTO WEAR EM ON
BUT AT'S MOSTLY T BLOCK THE SE,
SMELL OF.
NOW THAT T MANDATE S BEEN
RULED UNCONSTITUTION, THE TSA
LL NO LONGER ENFORCED SKS AT
RPOR.
WORD  THE CONSTUTIONALITY
CHARGING $ FOR A ICKEN
SANDCH,  I RIGHT?
SOME IN THE MEDIAERE NOT
EASED.>> IYOU THINK SHE WAS NOT
E GRADUATED FR LAWCHOOL,
IMAGINE W NOT QUALIFIE SHEIS
TOAKE PUBLIC HETH DECISIONS
ABOUT TRYI TO NTROL HIGHLY
INCTIOUS DEADLY PANDEMI.
>> JUDGE APPOIED BY NALD
TRUMP IN THE LA DAYS OF HIS
PRESENCYOUND UNQUALIFI BY
THABA ANDSHE WAS 33EARS OLD
WH SHE WAS CONFIRMED.
MANYOTHER JUDGES VE FND
THAT THIS MANDATWASEGAL.
IT I A CRAZY WAY THAVE A
DICIAL SYSTEM.
>> GET A GRI.
I MEAN THAT PSYCHOLOCALLY.
TRUMPET ONLY 3.RIDA APINTED BY
LEGAL ARGUMENTHEY ASSASSINATE
THE CHACTE
AREN'T YOU INTEREST IN THE HOLD
OUT, TH LASHED OTHE MASK AS SOMT
.
IT'S KE A BUMRSTICKER, IT
SAYSERE YOU E COMING IN
CAN'T TAKE IT OFF.
>> PEOPLE ARSTILL GOING TO
WEAR SKS D S I'M ONE OF
THE GOOD ONES.
BUT  SUCKS  WEAR A MASK
EVYBOD KNOWS THAT.
I WONDER HOW LONG THEY WILL KEE
ITOING.
BUT ALSO  ALLHIS UFF WAS
TRUE THERE WOU'VE EN SOME
PUSHBACK.
,.
>> KNOW GOES BACK TO E
THING WHERE TRE ALWAYS H TO
BE T SIDES SO IT'S LIKEF THE
LE SEES.
THEY THINK T MASSHOULD BE F.
YOU CAN SAY THAT IT ON.
DEFINILY SAY IT'S ON.
>> FEEL LIKE IS ANARTRARY POSIT.
>> LIKE IT'S A TRIL NEGATIVE
PARTISANSH FOR SURE.
WE MAY NEED A REMEDIAL
DISCUSON IN THIS COUNTRY AUT
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SOMEING
NOT BEG REQUIRED AND SOMETHING
BEING BANNEDECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
EATING IT LIKE THISJUDGE JT
YOND MASKSINAMERICA A THE
ARDEFIANTLY STILL WEARING THEM
EY'RSTICKING IT TO THIS
JUE,O, THEHOLE INT IS WE
CAN KE DECISIONSOR OSELVES
BASED ON OUOWN SK PROFILES AND
MASKS FOR TH RT OF THR
LIS, THAT'S IRDBUT GO FOR
IT.
I'VE SEEN T DEOS ON
RPLAS AND PEOPLE CHRING
D CELEBRING, WAS ON THE
ESLLA COMING  HERE WHEN THI
CAME DO, AN THE COUCTOR GOT
OFFMID TRA RIDE TO ANNOUNCE
THAT THIS WAS NO LGER REQUIRED
AND THE S NO CHEERING.
SECRLY OPLE WERE KINDF LOOKINGR
MA FOR A GOODNUMB OF PEOE
BECAUSIT'S LLYAND MASKS AR
MASK ON A TRAII ALWA WEAR A
>> I ULD LIKE T KNOW WHAT
CAUSEDHE LAUGH.
>> I DOT KW WHY IT JUST
SMELLS ON TRAINS.
YOU KN WH MAYING?
>> BUT WOU YOUEAR THEM ON
PLANES?
>>.WHAT ABOUT THCLASS STINCTION
THAT MASK SEE TOPURVEYISTHAT TH?
ISTH THE RIGH WORD?
>> IT'S A RDCONVEYURVEY.
WHEN YOUSI DOWN TO VE IO.
SOMETHING TO EAT AT RESTAURANT
WHEN YOU'RNOT WEARINA SK
ANEVERYONE SAVI IT IS
ARING MASKS.
I FIND THAT ZARRBECAUSE
LA BARE THE CLS DISTINION
BEEEN THE PEOPLEHAT RK
THERE.
TH BOTHERS ME.
THAT'S GOT TO STOP.
SO Y THINK WE SHOULD BEQUAL?
KE COMMUNIST D SOCIIST
RELY?
EMMA FREE-MART NARCO
PITALIST.
>> I'M HING ON AIRANES D I
WILL BE THE FIRS E TO SAY IT.
I WILLTAKE THE BACKSH, BUT IF
MEONE IS CK AND COUGNG
WHE I'M EATINGMY PREPARED
MICROWAVEMEAL ECONOMY CLASS,
I THINK THEY OULDE WEARING MASK.
SOME ETIQUET, US THE RIGHT
FORK FOR DINNER AND PUT ON E
SK IYOU'RE SICK.
>> IT SITUATION.
WE' NOT SEEING IT SHLD BE
BAED, WHICH IS SAYING.
>> EVERYBODY HAS MASK ON AND
THEY SEEK HIMWITHULLET DOWN
FOR ME.ALL THETIME.
I'VE EN ISO MANY TIME.
CAUS YOU DON' WANT TOET
BOOKS IN YOUR OWMASK
IF IT'S RBULCE I'M PULLIN
IT DOWAND PUKG ALL OVER YO
>> IR ENOUGH.TICKET THEY NEED T
A COMBINATION MA AND THEN YOU
CAN TURN YOURSELFINTOHUMANS
WHO BROKE AND LET EVERYONE KNOW
WHERE YOU STAND ON EVERY IUE.
>> THEY ARE TATING IT KE IT'S A
A BUMP STICKER WOULDAUSE YOU
TWO VISUALE WOD PEACE.
IT'S A FLAG.
LIKE I SA, NO ONE IS TAKIN
THR MAS AWAY.
YOWEAR AS MANY MASKS AS YOU
WANTAS LONG  YOU WANT, IT'S
SOSTRAE.
DID TH THINK 'S NER GOING TO EN.
TH 1918 PANDEMICNDED AND THERE .
THERHAS  BE A INT WHERE WE COME
WANTO LET IT GO BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THIS IRRAONALEELING LIKE Y
TRUMPISH  THEI SI,WILL
THEN ALL WERE 30 MAS AND ALL
WRAP MY HEAD IN DUCT TA.
AT'S WHAT YOU WANT TO DO
GO AHEAD, BUOTHER PEOPLE AREREA.
LET PEOPLE GETACK TO NORMA
LIVE.
>> GOOD MOE ENNG WITH
APPOINTED UMPAPPOINTED JUDG
THE JUDGEOW WHEN THEAPPOINTED